hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of [ __ ]
boys - alright so what we're about to
fight the last balloon boy I'm guessing
which means that this game is almost
over and I probably missed the whole
bunch of [ __ ] like I know I have but at
this point
God doesn't matter because [ __ ] it I'm
drunk as [ __ ] these these extra big
shots ain't doing much for me for the
benefit of my gameplays Jesus I filled
that up
[ __ ] big Jesus look at this [ __ ] like
Full Metal Alchemist is over this [ __ ]
a little shadow with the flask cuz
everyone is kept up with me thus far
like you guys are awesome I love you to
death and I'm not just saying that for
us I'm drunk cuz I say well sorry that's
why I said last ones cliche at this
point but you guys are awesome oh yeah
oh that one went down rough oh oh no it
was a rough one jeez those shots are big
I tried to do it in one go but Oh bad Oh
[ __ ] criminy Christmas holy dick
[ __ ] waggly [ __ ] tit boggling
mother home for pieces [ __ ]
oh okay so now we we need to fight
Balloon Boy but I'm just making sure
that I got all the items seems to be a
lot of cake I'm assuming that I'm gonna
be knocked out a whole bunch in this one
alright suing the way Balloon Boy you
[ __ ] I'm gonna show you what 400 that
brought tears last shot brought tears
alright you found me you weren't that
hard to find [ __ ] [ __ ] paid my wrath
I just fought you Jesus ah alright
level max okay guts good Jesus I use a
lot of skill though screaming his face
there's no time so I can actually plan
out what I'm doing
back up bash scream plank walk paralyze
one of these please no oh God
holy [ __ ] no wonder no wonder I needed
all those [ __ ] cakes
Jesus okay you do oh [ __ ] Jesus that did
so much okay you give a large soda to
Freddy
mangle you para jolt back up bash with a
chica you're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
gonna scream flag walk God paralyze this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
Jesus you do that Tim you keep trying to
stop him because it's the only way this
[ __ ] gonna work
[ __ ] I just gotta keep trying to stun
him but Jesus with her chica Jesus God
just [ __ ] paralyze him yes okay good
the god damn it's about damn time
holy [ __ ] it duck oh my god
scream on him terror fever good do that
I don't know what that is but it sounds
great
kay caught him do I have any other
people knocked out I do withered chica
keep him locked up whoa a new skills
learn what's that mean hit him hit him
hit him head of head of head of head of
him hit him hit him scream plankton
walk the plank yeah [ __ ] way withered
Bonnie with a chica both mtech it 100
why didn't I do something with that I'll
[ __ ] he's no longer paralyzer which
means that I'm [ __ ]
come on she's paralyzed and please
paralyze my need and paralyzed I need
him paralyzed
how about speech yeah that sounds good
oh there goes toy chica there goes my my
resurrection I think oh man I'm like I'm
like legitimately I'm pretty drunk at
this point mostly just cuz of how much
[ __ ] I've had to drink like those big
shots holy [ __ ] I was a mistake you
who's a goddamn mistake but hey it seems
okay now why not oh okay here we go God
feel the pain you [ __ ]
why does Balloon Boy get two forms both
like one tougher than the other like
it's such [ __ ] like why should this
be a thing God and all these like Cabo
attacks don't do a goddamn thing to him
Jesus but mangoes that 100 so I can do
bite of 87 on this [ __ ] okay everyone's
gonna focus on getting cakes up because
[ __ ] these cakes like goddammit I gotta
get mangle up it's just got to happen
and if this could paralyze it'd be great
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes okay good
I'm happy now I am very happy okay got
that terror fever love it skills okay
not you medium soda on him the bite of
87 the final attack back abashed that
bitch-ass pizza I'm playing why a son of
a [ __ ] huh I'm ready for this oh my god
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah that's
right get [ __ ] you dick
holy [ __ ] I guess I needed to use the
bite of 87 to win that I'm scared to
there toy Bonnie I know like the cool
kids cause all the cool
okay I did it
I babe whoa whoa [ __ ] Jesus oh [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ] I know there's a lot of
Secrets that I missed but frankly I
don't think I can get to him holy [ __ ] I
had like a tough time getting through
this goddamn game with you about it
shells like holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] holy god
damn but anyway thank you everybody for
being with me through this long I have
drug as [ __ ] but like I just want you
guys though like I don't get drug that
often the only reason I do this is
because I thought it'd be a cool idea to
do this so like I know moderation I know
moderation I know responsibility like I
don't want to encourage people to like
drink their asses off like that's not
what I'm trying to do what I'm trying to
do is just like have fun and there's
this point to that there's a point to
having fun for the sake of having fun
and I hope you guys enjoyed this series
as much as I have now there's one more
game after this but it's not out yet
five guys to [ __ ] boys three is not
released the developer says hey he's
trying to get it out this month but who
knows like when it comes out I'll do the
same thing I did for this one I'm gonna
take shots I'm gonna have a great time
because [ __ ] man like this is like the
whole reason I'm alive this is the whole
reason I do this like I [ __ ] love
doing this and I love the fact that you
guys watch me now I said in the last
series for five nights to [ __ ] boys one
like I said the real [ __ ] like some real
[ __ ] about the reality of what YouTube
is and what it is like to access the
boss race AR to you I don't know what
that is you guys find out what that is
like seriously I don't know what that is
but anyway I said some like real [ __ ]
about what YouTube was like and how hard
it was to get into YouTube and the fact
that the reason I'm so grateful about
what I have
okay I recommend you guys play this game
for yourself if you want to find out the
secrets this game but anyway like I said
some real [ __ ] about the reality of
YouTube and like how hard it is for
people to you started but what I didn't
met I didn't mean to discourage people
like that I just meant to show them what
it's really like and how difficult it is
to gets hurt in YouTube because it's not
easy it's but as with anything what I
try to say and what I try to get people
to understand is that if you're
discouraged by that you never wanted to
do with in the first place you were not
that committed in any regard if you are
seriously fiery burning passion towards
something even youtuber or anything else
nothing will get in your way you have a
passion you need to pursue it you need
to pursue it with reckless abandon to
the point that everything seems
nonsensical and everyone tells you that
you need to quit like when people tell
you to quit that's how you know you're
on the right path cuz you gotta pursue
it with reckless abandon with every
fiber your being you got do what you
want to do to the point that there's
nothing else that could even be an
option that's what I bet but either way
all in all I just want you guys have fun
like I want you guys have fun watching
my videos I want you guys to have fun
like playing the games that I play so
thank you everybody so much sincerely
from the bottom my heart like I love you
guys to death I love the fact that I'm
able to do this I love the fact that you
guys support me and I want to support
you equally in return but just know the
reality of the situation and know that
if you have conviction enough you can do
absolutely anything so thank you
everybody so much for watching watch the
original 5 biases and fuckboys one down
the description below or my five nights
at freddys thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]